and here we go again and the Press
having yet another field day after
former president Trump got indicted for
a fourth time a Georgia grand jury
hitting Trump and 18 others with a
staggering 41 counts prosecutors
accusing Trump of being the head of a
criminal Enterprise to overturn the 2020
election and they are using the RICO Act
that's a statute normally reserved for
mob bosses the media and Democrats like
Hillary Clinton could not help but gloat
as the news broke
Madam Secretary fancy meeting you oh I
can't believe this yeah this is not the
circumstances in which I expected to be
talking to you he had another set of
indictments if Trump or another
Republican wins they can pardon their
way out of that Jack Smith case or just
order doj to drop the case this is the
insurance so it should be big I think
it's done carefully it's done well
forgotten that Beyonce's tour hit uh hit
Atlanta tonight she did say
I can smell the dishonesty on your
breath this is a tour de force hers was
carpet bombing them into Smithereens
it's shocking off it's much bigger than
Watergate it's of a whole different
dimension uh it goes to the very
Foundation of democracy
new charges and trial dates now on a
collision course with the election
season Trump's calendar is already
pretty loaded with the three other
indictments he's facing so far across
the country the former president faces
91 charges in four jurisdictions the
Georgia D.A wants to try all 19
defendants at the same time and she
wants to do it all within six months
Trump and his team are slamming the
latest indictment
they're all chomping at the bit aren't
they and it's ironic that they waited
two and a half years to try and now have
it in six months the reason was they
wanted to mess them up right in the
middle of a campaign they wanted to line
him up so that he's tied up in court
last four weeks ago they can't win
against him otherwise so this is
desperation at its best Greg is this
worse than Watergate well I guess the
worst and Watergate guy wasn't available
so they got another worse than Watergate
guy to take his place he's like the B
level worse than water he's John Dean
he's definitely no Carl Bernstein or
maybe I have them confused I don't know
just remember Democrats and meet it you
will never be able to contest another
election as long as you live and you
love doing it no more you're not going
to be able to do that and unless your
candidate is a pre-chosen one by the
establishment you will be targeted with
lawfare which means your staff and your
lawyers and your family will be sued and
charged because all of these indictments
are meant to send a warning everybody
else don't work with Trump right so you
will lose a lot of time you will lose
your mind you will lose a lot of money
so if you're on the opposition you're
watching this show right now and
laughing and you because you're getting
what you're applauding you're applauding
something that isn't moral at all it's
something that is emotional and kind of
petty but it's going to come back to
bite you in the ass if you're a
republican all right this has to be
exhausting it has to be confusing it has
to be overloading because it never stops
that's the point they're trying to wear
you down wearing somebody down is a is a
type of persuasion it's the political
version of Brute Force you know
submitting endless passwords uh hoping
that eventually you'll guess it
correctly that's what the indictments
are doing they're constantly putting
this in here even the the attempt itself
is tiresome because you have to deal
with it you're the machine that responds
this is the largest political
cancellation in history it's a bloodless
assassination they want you to freak out
over it you need not to the scarier
response is silence because that means
you take it more seriously than they'll
be aware of the Democrats and then I'll
shut up
are using this reality show Trick if
they pile on the events right whether
it's challenges if you ever watch any
reality show they start stacking the
events uh challenges obstacles stunts
they're trying to get the most visual
memorable thing to happen and that's
what they're doing they want you to
freak out they want you to blow your
mind but no just go back to work and
settle it that way judge before 906 a.m
this morning on Newsroom both Jonathan
Turley and former Governor Chris
Christie who is also a GOP candidate had
called the latest indictments that they
read excessive and unnecessary is that
sort of the consensus that you're seeing
on that side of the aisle well I think
that four indictments in five months is
a bit excessive oh I think it kind of
reeks of uh as Elena Haba said
desperation but here's my concern look
there's an issue that has to do with a
preemption okay and the truth is that
we've got Jackson at the special counsel
in Washington who've already indicted
Trump for attempting to unlawfully
overturn an election and in that
indictment are several references to the
Georgia statute specifically of section
10B 12a 21 ABC 21 through 33. uh and
what does that tell you why am I
blathering on about that what it tells
you is that the feds have already
indicted him for this she then as a
local D.A is precluded from going
forward with her own indictment it
doesn't work in the reverse but when the
feds come in the local can't follow up
and say I'm going to indict them too no
you can't there are procedural issues
and then there's collateral estoppel
which is another legal term that I
apologize for if in the event there is a
conviction or a a plea that would
prevent him from being tried in state
court on the very issues that Jack Smith
uses now let me see a couple things this
all has has to do with Donald Trump's
State of Mind the issue is is it
criminal to pursue the legal means or
legal means to disagree with an election
results and if that's true then Stacey
Abrams Hillary Clinton Bush V Gore let's
talk about the lawyers in Bush V Gore
didn't they have meetings with lawyers
and say did we get this many votes in
that state did we get this cement what
about those hanging Chads in your county
should we make all of those meetings uh
illegal and part of a conspiracy and by
the way the RICO statute that's just
theater that's just a bunch of theater
in the midst of uh politics and a legal
thing the issue is not whether he wanted
to overthrow it but did he believe that
he won if he believed that he won
pursuing all these Avenues are okay for
him because in themselves they are not
illegal if you say look I need to find
eleven thousand votes that's very
different from saying I need you to find
me eleven thousand votes somewhere he
just knows he's behind by eleven
thousand seven hundred votes and finally
uh did he know he lost and did he then
pursue all these Avenues or did he
believe he won and was doing everything
he can it's going to be very hard to
prove that Harold Ford Jr your thoughts
I differ with my friend the judge on
this for a couple reasons first you I
lost an election before for the United
States Senate back in 2006 in Tennessee
and there were those that told me to
contested contest it I believe the vote
count and I lost about a few dozen
thousand votes you have every right to
contest any race my father when he first
was elected to congress in 1974 they
reported that he lost that night he went
down to the election commission and
confronted them and said I want to I
want to get an understanding of what's
going on here it turned out they had not
counted eight of the biggest Democratic
precincts in the city and he won his
race do you think it was on purpose we
learned later was definitely on purpose
anybody even had a racial Dimension to
it hi winner Brian Kim lead I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now